Congress narrowly avoided a historic
default that for months threatened to
shake the global economy in his first
address from the Oval Office the
president said the debt ceiling deal
averts economic collapse the U.S jobs
Market remains strong despite a
stalemate in negotiations last month
employers added 339 thousand jobs in May
to Mark the 29th consecutive month of
positive job growth Wall Street rallied
behind the surprisingly strong jobs
report and the debt ceiling deal vote
the Dow surged more than 700 points for
a 2.1 percent gain on Friday the S P 500
and the NASDAQ also climb more than one
percent Christina raffini reports from
the White House Christina good morning
good morning Jeff as you mentioned this
was President Biden's first address from
behind the Resolute desk and look
neither side was particularly thrilled
with what they ended up with with this
last minute deal but negotiators say
that's exactly why it worked
no one got everything they wanted but
the American people got what they needed
we averted an economic crisis an
economic collapse the message of
President Biden's Friday night address
was less mission accomplished and more
crisis averted passing this budget
agreement was critical
the stakes could not have been higher
kicking off the summer with a rare
Congressional compromise on this vote
the A's are 63 the Nays are 36. the
measure to raise the debt ceiling and
cut federal spending past both Chambers
with bipartisan votes you know the Biden
McCarthy deal is not conservative in any
way shape or form this isn't the piece
of legislation I would write but at the
same time we can't risk defaulting and
in another bright spot for the economic
Outlook
Friday's jobs report the American
economy added nearly twice as many jobs
last month as expected more than three
hundred thousand you know we ask our
employees do you know of anyone looking
for a part-time full-time work but that
hiring boom could mean the economy is
still overheated forcing the Federal
Reserve to keep taking action against
inflation the FED is actually now in a
tough position they may be forced to
raise interest rates by another quarter
of a percentage point because the labor
market is still fairly strong
the White House says the president will
likely sign that compromise bill as soon
as later today but for at least one of
the credit rating agencies the deal
didn't come soon enough and they're
keeping the U.S on a watch list for a
potential downgrade Dana
just like any normal person would be all
right Christina thank you